on va démarrer avec le cadeau de bachar
al assad
est ce que tu m'as offert belle vous
venez ouvrir le oui est franchement vous
a déjà des amours d'abord offert un
cadeau s'est offert par la prod ou par
vous alors c'est personnel attaquants
parce que c'était la pratique et moi qui
ai payé ses personnels et c'est un beau
cadeau
mais ça ça c'est un symbole c'est hulk
ouais attendez vous aimez les super
héros
12h02 s'accorder en fait non mais non
mais qu'est-ce que je me fous de tout ça
donc oui tu aimes le foot roux olza est
coffré coffret collector non on 75 ans
de la voiture marvel atteint les brodard
les bronches un très très beau livre
franchement vous n'êtes pas foutus de ma
gueule non
c'est ce que j'ai fait des séances d'uv
je prends pas merci je me rends pas
malade mais naim alors venez nous alors
benhaim et je tiens à ciney cave a déjà
offert un cadeau oui mais on s'en fout
un deuxième cadeau offert une bague dans
ma loge la dernière fois tu vois tout le
monde je les fais exprès mais alors par
contre j'adore mais sont les pires elles
sont enfin au cumin et je vous les
étendues c'est vraiment au cumin bien
non les deux d'une lourdeur parce que de
nier la 10e cumin c'est un machin là
ouais ouais tant qu'humain excusez le
mans j'aime beaucoup ça c'est vraiment
beinheim qui les accueillent je vous
jure que ça vous dirait des trucs pour
chiens ont pas mal non non mais bon on
sait qu'on verra pas le cas samedi
jusqu'à la fin
[Applaudissements]
jean michel merle allez vas-y vous
remercie encore je suis assez lourde
heures à bord une odeur genre un livre
c'est le sexe ou les nuls
aulas a apporté que ses pieds une
horreur alors si vous voulez vomir vous
enchaînez sar avec les boulettes de
viande alors franchement c'est sûr mais
aimez vos pieds au pire on dirait qu'on
les a coupé à la scie à la fin j'en
avais tu n'as pas un peu trop la fine en
p3 pas pkoi pas un oignon non c'est pas
un oignon la farce et une cela me suis
alors j'ai rien compris bon anniversaire
baboune et moi ça fait huit ans que je
prends mon pied a way
vous êtes légende c'est très sympa alors
lui il est vers vous bah oui barroso
[Rires]
alors c'est un taux qui est un peu
exceptionnel c'est mon premier tour de
magie cela passera bien tellement le
dernier aussi je me suis entraîné vers
les 2 3
[Musique]
il était censé fonctionner vas-y vas-y
fais-le vite mascara pas tant il va le
faire
il va le faire en facebook sur le
facebook l'a élaboré ici on l'a juste
pendant la pub tout à l'heure et on va
voir si russie réussit pas de son temps
qui réussit pas on rentre pas dans
l'émission ça va la barbe
à vous alors tiao a pas de sot pourquoi
parce que je vous ai fait une peinture
avec trois choses que j'adore
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est pas tout alors que les trois
choses qu'il aime c'est quoi fatou oui
une margarita et mon nez jettent un jour
[Applaudissements]
lire
ça va se vendre très cher mamie qu'est
ce qu'est la fema me regarder alors si
vous nous rejoignez les formes sont avec
nous mais ça fait quoi ça d'abord des
empereurs légiste square et toi tu as
well fait le point elle le connaît par
coeur à la fin poèmes bon dieu vient des
jolies femmes tu as un long couteau tu
fais une fine lame vous aime tous
vacanciers et tailler dans le vif
tout est frais raudière qu'aujourd'hui
tu as dans le pif mais moi que mon
cadeau te plaise ou ta support c'est
avec tout mon coeur que la jetée la
porte
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez vous regardez ce que
m'en faire elle m'en faire dit mais
allemand faire elle m'a offert des
couteaux tu m'as pris pour nabil
[Rires]
c'est avec ça qu'on l'a circoncis
[Applaudissements]
oui mais j'étais bien tu prends la carte
tu fais ça court
dingue non mais t'es pas tu crois
vraiment que je prends mon frère et ça
va prendre de là que ça va prendre
encore plus de valeur c'est parce qu'ils
arrêtent la production parce que
justement et cet espoir s'est
franchement c'est magnifique a toujours
été dans la poche ce à quoi quand je
loupe c'est comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est allé chercher spécialement savoie
samedi avec l'ossature plus embrasser
alors c'est que c'est un truc de
vieilles les poèmes parce que c'est un
poème aussi tu veux pas le faire pour
moi je savais pas que vous offrir genève
était à disneyland ce week-end regardez
ah ça va vous laisser vous les suresnois
là bas alors si ça pouvait disparaître
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
corps et vous êtes à l'amour et jolie je
lirai le projet intervient il est henri
munich comme henri munich
ouais alors je le vois là comme ça il
est un peu long ses avocats c'est donc
vers bercy alors bon on verra ça demain
une balle de tennis
j'ai un message pour vous quoi qu'ils
ont là un message de quelqu'un qui vous
en prie ton anniversaire il pas lui
aussi tout est cassé 15,3 en magique
c'est pas mal mais je pense qu'on peut
faire beaucoup mieux quand même un noir
comptent sur moi je te promets grande
leçon je fais pas c'est comment est ce
que je vais te fais un beau circuit
amateurisme a fini le petit cassement à
quinze jours elle est terminée avait
quand même un joyeux anniversaire à toi
désormais de très bons cadeaux merci à
mon pied est alors alors à part les
séances d'uv
ah mais oui mais alors c'est à dire ton
pote de moines y a un truc sinon c'est
moi qui laissait le porte clés de ma
maison du pilat voilà que je voudrais
mais tu as pas mis les clefs dont on
connaît madden aux portes au québec je
verrai territoire la maison c'est quoi
la maison je vous donne c'est le
porte-clés tout ça pas mal de la maison
tu la gagnes en faisant trois
instructions vidéo gag le bronze à petit
comme les jolies de relance qui est bien
sûr très bien merci et bajjaje le mail à
merci et kelly alors qu'eddy qu'est ce
que la ram attendait les deux déjà
tenait tacle bac je vous rends ça et je
vous l'offre d'ailleurs merci ça ne sert
à rien
[Applaudissements]
d'accord je prends et d'ensuite donc
c'est à moi maintenant
ouais c'est normal juste à la prod geste
n'avait pas les moyens pour m'acheter un
rétroviseur
ouais donc j'ai pris une photo de ma
tronche je vous la met ici bon rien
manquer je vous souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire et c'est justin bieber
voilà
j'adore et je vous le mets ici comme ça
vous n'oubliez pas mais il ya les
missions non non non non ça me plait
monsieur tous avouent 60 et très piégeux
mais la merci